on s'est fait attaquer une personne a
mal parlé de nous une personne qui a
pignon sur rue et je peux vous dire que
quand j'ai appris ça s'était jetée au
bout de ma vie c'était en pls ça s'est
passé chez jordan de luxure non-stop
people grosse fiesta
il ya quelqu'un qui a expliqué qu'il
avait pas trop kiffé
venir dans tpm pays cette personne la
première chose que je me suis dit quand
je les ai vus
qui c'est qui c'est on avait invité sept
personnes dans des bennes ne savait pas
et ça m'a fait mal
m à deux elles oui bal avec deux amis
parce que j'ai eu envie de me parler je
vous demander de regarder ce qui s'est
passé est renvoyé comment s'est passé
bien écoute ça s'est passé comme un hold
up
c'est à dire c'est à dire que je devais
faire cette émission
et puis le jour j j'arrive là-bas on dit
bon vous faites pas le plateau
finalement vous chantez ces démissions
un petit pot il ya une bande
d'incapables autour de la table non mais
c'est qu'une fois que j'étais là bas on
m'a pris pour un idiot est tout
simplement au moment avant de passer
j'ai dit écoutez puisque c'est comme ça
je m'en vais et on sait que lorsqu'on va
lors d'une émission comme ça on sait
qu'on va se faire taper sur la gueule ou
mieux qu'on ne va pas nous laisser la
parole
ce qui aurait créé des choses à dire et
des tv alors seibert déformant aux mères
et des bébés à la banane sur autour de
la taille c'est plus sur la tête là
c'était sympa mais malheureusement il
s'est acharné sur une personne s'est
faussement c'est pas votre jours comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
il avait personne dans le pif plus que
les autres ouais a dit à nous d'aller
gagner là ça va - reste à 10 appareils
vous l'avez reçu un vendredi
je me rappelais pas et bavois lui les
appels à wels et je peux vous dire
apparemment ouais il vous kiffe mais en
tous les cas dans ce genre d'émissions
auxquelles je suis allé et celle de
castaldi c'est encore pire alors parce
que lui à l'horloge quand je le vois on
dit bonjour c'est très gentil garçon
mais alors il a très très peur qu'on lui
pique la vedette mais ça c'est le lot de
beaucoup de présentateur est latent mais
je vous le dis et voilà donc j'ai peur
de qui me prennent abonnés de lui et le
vendredi 13 mai au centre et je
regardais les champs avec vous il est
sympa et que quand ils vous voyez il
vous serrer la main mais comme vous et
moi ça tombe bien moi plus folles
mais bert même avec ces nouveaux yeux et
oeuvrait qu'une toute petite
elle est en vacances
gk sis à cocody j'étais content j'ai un
côté de berardi il est resté une heure
dans les âges tous à la toile
cette bonne mais pas il est quand même
assez courageux de dire ça c'est pas
trés mais ces attaques hier voilà c'est
pas très méchant il ose s'attaquer une
émission sauf que tout quoi la lada non
musulmans vous avez quoi peut-être un
vitrail n'offrait pas lâché mais la
guigne bande de débiles quant à kaba je
vais vous dire avec moi ça passera pas
d'usagé de la sacem
[Applaudissements]